what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting to a
video titled power of the
and being honest rules of modern dating
and understanding
before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel as you guys
know i'm trying to hit 20 000
subscribers and hit that notification
bell okay just so you guys
know this was sent to me on instagram so
if you guys have any videos you want to
submit dm me on instagram it's
the best way to get a hold of me when
you're in a bar or a club and you see a
man you're attracted to
how do you hit on him what do you do how
do i hit him with him
okay yeah yeah okay so i'm gonna give
him that little side eye
uh-huh look at him look at him for three
seconds
and then don't look for the rest of the
time what if you're wearing some fly ass
sunglasses like you are right now
usually it's the look you know if i'm
like kind of looking at you giving you
the
eye and whatnot and then sometimes if
like you're attractive enough like i'll
just you know shoot my shot
i don't hit on him i look at him if he
looks at me we make eye contact and it's
up to him to make the next move i don't
hit on guys
i feel like if he wants me then he gonna
come to me
do you guys think as man like since the
majority of my
subscribers are men let me know in the
comments if you think that
is enough if a woman isn't willing to
shoot her shot
does that mean she is not all that into
him no
she probably just will she's waiting for
you to take yeah she's playing hard
again and she's waiting for you to
shoot your shot okay what's the
difference between a woman who's playing
hard to get and a woman who's just not
interested
okay a woman who is playing hard to get
yeah she's going to play little games
she's going to tease you
a woman who's not interested just going
okay at least i go with me
if i'm not interested i'm going to tell
you i'm not interested you're going to
know
but if i'm you know playing not playing
games with you but if i'm interested in
you
i'm going like you know what i'm saying
i'm gonna make it known you gonna know
that i like okay
well like what signals do you send um
[Music]
hmm that's a good question okay i mean
if it
fits you first i mean if it's so obvious
that a guy should know
then
oh my god this man is funny
i get yeah that's true but sometimes we
don't know
sometimes i don't be well right but if
you yeah a lot of girls i think are
undecided like they're not sure at first
i don't know yourself then why would a
guy know
that's a good question
okay and how would he know that you're
in don't ask women we don't know
more than a friend well
i would either well it depends i don't
know it depends how
he reacts to my question you know if i
even wanna
take it further and then depending on
that then i'll make it very clear you
know
okay how would you make it very clear
asking if you know
well if you know like maybe if he wants
to dance like hey do you wanna dance
oh okay that's cool why do you think a
lot of women would prefer to send subtle
hints rather than just be direct
well everyone's definitely different um
i think it's more important to be more
direct like obviously start off subtle
i would say that some girls don't want
to be the one like
chasing if that makes sense like i
um yeah that's like my two cents just
from what i've like
seen but then you need to ask before you
make any type of move you know
so either yeah you want to dance or like
if you wanted to take it further
just ask you know why is it when it
comes to a woman's education
or her career being assertive and going
after what you want is a good quality
why not also in dating because i think a
lot of girls get caught in the trap
where they're like doing everything and
putting in all the effort
and they don't want to do that just my
guess is what she's gonna say
assertive in dating yeah most women will
like wait for a man to approach them why
do you think
when it comes to okay well i just want
to feel like
i'm wanted yeah but you gotta want me
you gotta if you want me you gotta apply
pressure
yeah you gotta apply pressure baby if
you're not applying pressure
there's somebody else that will take
your place so apply pressure
uh well i think obviously there is a
double standard you know if women are
more direct but
hopefully that's kind of going away you
know um
i don't know i haven't really heard too
much of bad stigmas about you know
it being looked down upon a woman like
being direct you know i'm very direct i
like to make it very clear and i think
it's important that you should make it
very clear
be kind of assertive you know what do
you guys think about this do you think
that puts
women what do you guys say the masculine
energy like women too much in the
masculine well
at some point at least you know it
doesn't have to be right in the
beginning but
how would you feel if a woman approached
you oh they're about to tell
us this is interesting don't bother me
one bit uh would you be intimidated if a
woman offered to pay the bill
no but i'm still gonna pay him but you
know it's a nice gesture
would you be intimidated if she
initiated sex or made the first not at
all
why do so many women think that men
would feel emasculated
i don't know maybe that's the ego thing
with most of those men i don't
i don't think it's emasculated i think
it's they don't feel
valued oh that and stuff like that don't
bother me okay
does it actually is it flattering to you
do you like it yes
does no always mean no yes
no or well it kind of depends on
in the moment like if they're uh they're
actually hitting the spot
and they're like oh you want to go
deeper and like no but yes
yes but i tell you it's straight
no that means no you can i feel like you
can tell through body language and tone
so like whenever guys are kissing me i'm
like stop saying
so you should probably say it and not
text it right uh yeah yeah
it depends during sex no means no
no means [ __ ] no i'm gonna tell you
right now no means no during
during any sexual intercourse anything
exactly because then that can be
considered other things like rape or
whatever
okay so how do you how do you know the
difference like how can you tell
in like sex or in general uh just just
in any situation however you interpret
that question there's no right or wrong
answer
it depends how they say it so if they're
saying it in a funny way
like giggling and stuff then they're
joking they want you to continue
anything like not just in sex whatever
they want you to continue what's going
on they're just
having fun with trolling you but if
they're saying like
no drop the mic end that [ __ ] right
there don't don't fight with her
why do men continue to accept the idea
that they're expected to work or pay for
female attention
i mean because due to history at times
that's how it's been
okay but doesn't don't times change all
the time yeah true dead times do change
yeah but why do you think that we've
changed so much when it concerns women
but men are still playing by the same
old-fashioned gender roles
oh damn that's a good question that's
kind of stumped on that one
yeah i'm kind of stumped on that one do
you guys think because women have
changed men should change
too let me know in the comments got me
on that one
do you think that women are doing men a
favor by giving them sex
oh that's a perfect question for me huh
um
well i think for the moment but do i
think it's good for society as a whole
no well i think it kind of depends like
i think if someone's putting in the
effort and actually showing that they
want them and get to know them on a
personal level
yes then you get to have sex but if all
you want
is just sex then say that and then be
gone
okay don't don't leave me on don't try
and string it on like
she said if you want sex let me know if
you don't
then [ __ ] off and if it's just a hookup
yes you're entitled
why do so many women think they have the
golden [ __ ] when every woman has one
you know what cause men lie to them
that's why
men tell them that they [ __ ] is gold
when it's when it's just basic one one
one last quick question for yes
okay okay have you ever lied to a woman
in order to get laid
nah why do you think a lot of men lie to
women in order to get laid
that's the only way they can they tell
women what they want to hear
okay so it makes it easier for them why
can't men tell the truth
that's a good question i don't know they
want to get what you want
yeah i mean did the men feel like they
can't get what they want
personally i don't need a lot to get it
so i don't know why men feel they need
the lie just be honest with a woman
straight up and you know
she'll give it to you quick if you're
honest with him and let him know what it
is from the rep
do you guys think that's true or false
do you think
lying is required um would you prefer a
man who's completely honest or a man who
tells you what you want to hear
completely honest completely honest so
what if a man came up to you and said
i think you're really attractive if i
took you out and spent money on you and
made you laugh and feel special
would you be open to hooking up with me
and potentially something more
[ __ ] no but isn't that completely honest
it is completely honest but
isn't that literally what happens yeah i
don't know not every man thinks like
that
some people actually genuinely want to
get to know you
but but if those are your intentions
then i know your intentions are just to
hook up then no
okay um what is the difference between
being completely honest
and being too blunt
that one's hard and
shoot say it again what is the
difference between being completely
honest and being too blunt
okay so being too blunt is being like
super straightforward like
uh well that's like honesty too that's
kind of like no but
hold on so say someone asked you like oh
do you think i'm attractive or not
you say no i think you're [ __ ] ugly
leave me the [ __ ] alone that's too blunt
um if you're being honest i'm sorry i'm
not attracted to you
but i'm sure you'll find somebody but
thank you or you're just not there's a
difference
that's actually that was a good
explanation between the difference
between being too blunt and on it's like
when you take it a step further and go
too far like take it from the yes or no
question
and instead have to give details of like
why you don't find that much that was a
good
attractive that was a good
interpretation that's like a nicer way
of being honest
do you do you think that uh being too
blunt is similar
to being brutally honest yeah so there's
a difference in being completely honest
and being brutally honest
okay okay if a woman can wear wonder
bras to make her boobs look bigger
can men put socks in their jeans to make
their junk look bigger
i guess i don't know i wouldn't do it i
don't need to do that
okay uh well i mean can can men wear
lifts to make them look taller
i guess
[Laughter]
who is more likely to get plastic
surgery men or women
women is it fair because women are more
valued
on their looks than men are like there's
guys that get a ton of girls because
they're they're rich like look at hugh
hefner
for a woman to expect a guy to be
completely honest
when she has fake nails fake hair makeup
high heels breast implants etc
no i think those women are beyond
[ __ ] they go to the bar
pretending completely fake and then they
get home and like they take out their
butt implants
and they're giant double d push-up bras
and then they wipe their face clean
and they turn into like this ogre that
somehow
miraculously i've seen makeup like
tutorials that
like they turned an ogre or filters on
instagram oh my gosh some people i
literally
i have friends that i do not i did not
recognize in person like the first time
i met them if i saw them on instagram
first into a princess
fake nails fake hair makeup high heels
breast and no you can't have all that
fake stuff and want a real man
have you ever let a man on because you
enjoyed the attention you received
of course that's part of being a girl
okay do you believe
hey how many questions do we have here
have you ever heard the expression
power of the [ __ ] yes of course
what does that mean the girls run the
relationship
anything problems because at the end of
the day the guy wants the [ __ ]
and the only fans right yeah power of
the [ __ ] yeah only chance
exactly girls get paid from their i
think it's a weird dynamic when girls
have like
boyfriends or husbands and they haven't
only fans
that's so weird too you guys don't get
paid off their dick
i've never heard of it but it's true
okay what does that mean how would you
how would you define that
that means that i have all the power and
anything that i want the dude has to do
before he can get what i got going on
here
okay so then why do you think there's so
much talk in our society about things
like
male privilege and white privilege but
we never talk about [ __ ] privilege
i don't know because dudes are stupid
okay
damn this girl this girl was doing well
for the clickbait
oh my gosh are so many women reluctant
to admit that they have privilege
i don't know i'm not okay um
why do so many i have all the privilege
why why do so many women think they have
the golden [ __ ] when
every woman has one because some dudes
will be willing to pay anything to get
what you got between your legs and if
they're willing to pay for it
then you got to take it it'd be stupid
to not take it
okay um but isn't that an awfully
privileged position to be in
it is i just said that i was privileged
yeah he's trying to make her out to be
like she's not admitting this but she's
like openly admitting the privilege she
has as a female
the world revolves around positions we
run the world baby basically
okay so i wouldn't go that far if the
power of the [ __ ] is so strong that men
will do almost anything for it
how exactly is it a man's world
it's not a man's world they just yeah i
just like to think that
well so then why is it then what do you
guys think i would say that
men run the world not women but i would
say women like hold great influence
like i would say melania trump like she
obviously didn't run the world when she
was married to donald but i'm sure she
had a lot of influence in like what she
did like she's a very smart woman and
that there's all this fighting for
equality that women
are always complaining about because men
don't
like to give that record i don't i
wouldn't say men but people don't like
to give that recognition to women
because even women will do that women
will not like to give recognition to
other women which is sad
right you know what i'm saying which is
sad we need to because a lot of women
view other women as competitors in the
dating market all uplift each other
i know the next question is going to be
bad yeah i can't i can't
exactly okay why do you think there is
so much talk in our society
about things like male privilege white
privilege but we never talk about [ __ ]
privilege
yo
he is so right like i don't even know
how to answer that because
there is a lot of privileges that come
with having a [ __ ]
it's did you guys hear about that study
where a girl
became a guy like she was a trans like
she became like a trans guy
and she was talking about how she didn't
even notice how much better people
treated her just because she was a girl
and growing up i always heard that
but i never really believed it but the
older i get the more like things are
pointed out to me that i never would
have thought about before
one of the most powerful privileges that
exists hell yeah
and it's never talked about why is that
because every man wants [ __ ] because
every man wants [ __ ]
say that again that's almost being
sexist aha interesting okay could it be
possibly because it destroys the victim
narrative sure
okay what does the expression power of
the [ __ ] mean
[Music]
[Music]
oh dear oh dear i'm trying to without
being real like
i would have [ __ ] there i guess since
it's a serious thing necessary
he just answered this question right now
it's a serious thing put it like this
the power of the [ __ ] causes people to
kill people
you know like damn god kill a guy over
that
really like seriously really so would
you say what women can use sex to
get men to do to get men to do anything
right yes
okay so my next question is why is there
so much discussion
in our society about things like male
privilege and white privilege but we
never talk about [ __ ] privilege
we why we don't talk about [ __ ]
privilege man [ __ ] make the world go
around man we
us men need that our strength didn't
need that
probably because then
all the guys listening to them wouldn't
get laid
we need that to survive without it we're
nothing
okay just just give me a rough estimate
how much of our economy
is driven by men buying things to please
and impress women
i think a small percentage we just don't
aren't purchasing decisions
made by like 80 or 85 percent women let
me know in the comments
more than 70 percent would you agree
that most consumer spending is geared
towards women
uh when they put it like that like who's
the stuff marketed towards
i get you i get you okay would you also
agree that the media
pushes a campaign of fear and
consumption
by exploiting men's need for female
validation
yes i feel like everything in the
economy has to do with women like
okay so why is there so much talk about
female exploitation
but we never talk about this
exploitation of men
because power of the [ __ ] sex sells
right
yes yeah okay and finally why is there
so much talk about a gender pay gap
but we never talk about a gender spend
gap
that's a good question oh my gosh i've
never thought about
that a gender spend gap i'm going to
start using that
and lastly lastly and lastly why
why do women want to earn as much as men
if they still expect men to pay for
everything
yo this went from a a regular interview
to
i i'm starting to hate women
and that's the man of sphere i swear to
god that's the man
he's right though he's right he's right
yeah yeah they're asking they're making
great
yeah they're asking for more money
making great points but
yeah to spend so do you think that
if the women are like making more money
they should spend
more like they should pay for everything
because the manuscript also
pushes like traditional roles so i'm
curious what you guys would say money on
themselves
yeah we're asking for my more money to
take girls out yeah
because look at the end of the day guys
have to ask girl on dates yeah when is
the last time a girl is going to ask a
guy for a date yeah
right and does it get any more privilege
than that
being approached right women don't
approach men i i love women
no no don't get me wrong i love women
too but i think
as well well well please say that again
by the way
i love when women approach me as well
why is that
because it makes me feel good okay so
the narrative you hear with a lot of
girls is that if you
do that like first or approach first
that that puts you
in like a like a place where you're
chasing
um like so i'm curious what you guys
would say
in the comments let me know never been
approached gives me confidence
you know what's funny it makes me know
that they want me you know what you know
for sure they want you
you know what's funny a lot of women
i've asked them why don't women
typically approach men
and a lot of them think that it actually
is like int men are intimidated by it
they don't like it and i'm saying
i think that's a myth i think women want
to feel special so do men
right yes correct the concept of men
trying to impress women
like i got a call i got a house i got
money
uh i can uh i can i can trick you
into liking me i can i can trap you i'll
say this man
uh so many things in this culture and
this life are about appearances right so
look let me let me let me
let me speak this little so like what is
a man
what is a woman you know as a man being
being strong being like buff and you
know like i'm a man i could protect you
i could provide for you there's a woman
saying oh
i can everything everything in this
place it's like it's about tricks man
so like this a man he work out at the
gym right so he looks strong
like i can i'm strong i can protect you
i got money i could provide for you but
are you providing what the woman
actually needs
that's a good question um and the woman
she watch this
plastic surgery i have fake lips i have
fake breasts i have fake butt
so it gives you the signal that
i i am fertile and i could produce a
healthy baby for you
but can you really produce a healthy
baby if you're full of plastic and
chemicals and fake things and are you
really providing a woman with
the protection that she really needs do
you guys care about like
the fake like lip fillers botox all that
stuff is that a turn off or would you
say
that it doesn't really matter you don't
care that's a sacred divine feminine
if you're jacked up on steroids and
testosterone
and craziness are you giving the woman
what she needs and is she giving you
what you really need
so i think the whole thing is skewed and
we have to
un take ourselves out of the whole
system thing and tap
in to ourself our innate biology
you know our innate spirit and soul
which everything is taking you away from
so it's all a game depending on the
perspective
this was a really interesting interview
it actually posed a lot of good
questions like i've never thought about
the
spending gap they said like if there's a
pay gap there's also a spending gap
never thought about that but let me know
in the comments what you guys think
do not forget to subscribe and ring the
notification bell